voilà un nouveau steak bien juteux sur
lequel se sont unanimement rejeté les
médias traditionnels français
quelques heures seulement après
l'annoncé par les autorités russes de
l'enregistrement d'un vaccin pour la
première fois au monde
voilà les réactions qu'on trouve dans la
presse française
et
et vous enfin on se détend l'espoir est
dans une classe d'école
le premier de la classe et d'excès qu'un
autre élève ait terminé son exposé avant
lui l'imi mieux c'est comme ça qu'il
faut faire j'aurais pu faire mieux
la russie a été le premier pays à
enregistrer le vaccin n'est pas encore
en vente
effectivement la dîmière poutine a fait
une annonce par visioconférence il a
expliqué espérer que le pays initierait
rapidement une production de masse de
doses prévues pour septembre pour que
tous ceux qui le souhaitent puissent se
faire vacciner c'est bien doit-on
rappeler qu'à l'heure actuelle ce sont
140 et un vaccin qui sont testés à
travers le monde 28 sont déjà dans la
phase d'un essai clinique qui compte 3
stade d'évaluation les commandes de
traitements expérimentaux se multiplient
et des tests d'autres vaccins sont en
cours dans d'autres pays à washington
donald trump a ainsi annoncé le soir du
11 août à contrat de 1,5 milliard de
dollars pour la livraison de 100
millions de doses du vaccin expérimental
de la biotech américaine moderna le
sixième contrats de ce genre depuis mai
en chine c'est le vaccin mis au point
par le laboratoire sinovac biotech
appelé corona bac qui est entrée dans la
dernière étape des essais cliniques
avant l'homologation et qui est déjà
testée sur neuf mille volontaires au
brésil le deuxième pays le plus touché
au monde par la pandémie de ports aux
navires us après les états unis
on à l'indonésie qui a commencé le 11
août à tester sur 1600 volontaire un
autre vaccin également en phase iii et
cetera et cetera et cetera
pourquoi tant de blabla pour l' annonce
de l'enregistrement d'un vaccin
devraient être contemple recherche
avance aucun état par l'allemagne qui a
fait part de son scepticisme et c'est
son droit de se prononcer sur la non ce
russe alors pourquoi tout ce remue
ménage dans les médias français nommé
c'est trop rapide normalement c'est plus
long la question de la vitesse ici est
en vérité relative cela dépende à partir
de quand on calcule le temps que nous
avons mis à l'élaboration du vaccin
nous avons commencé à travailler sur ces
technologies il ya déjà 25 ans il s'agit
du troisième ou quatrième vaccin que
nous fabriquons en nous basant dessus
par conséquent nous avions à certains
avantages
ok très bien ça se tient qu'en pense le
ms le vaccin russe a passé les deux
premières phases de tests et en est
actuellement à la troisième tout le
processus n'est pas complètement
terminée mais on estime que le vaccin
est prêt à être appliquée localement ou
au moins en russie nous sommes en
contact direct avec les autorités russes
et nous savons que la russie en général
dispose des capacités scientifiques et
techniques pour créer des vaccins de
haute qualité
l'om est ce n'est pas prête pour le
moment à dire si le vaccin répond
paramètres d'utilisation dans le monde
mais nous sommes quotidiennement en
contact avec les autorités russes
voilà c'est aussi simple que ça en fait
vous avez trouvé un vaccin on nous
assurer qu'il est effectif
vous comptez le rendre disponible à
partir de janvier 2021 tant mieux
continue à bosser tous ensemble nous
entrons dans une phase prometteuse sait
bien où est le problème en fait 20 pays
à travers le monde ont déjà fait part de
leur intention de commander le vaccin la
russie en majorité des pays d'amérique
du sud en particulier le brésil mais
également la jordanie ou encore la
serbie doit-on rappeler que nous
une société capitaliste où la
concurrence sur le marché est la base du
fonctionnement de la société
le domaine de la recherche échappe pas
il ne dit pas
[Musique]